welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is confirmed to be showing
two different versions circulating
throughout movie theaters at first we
heard of a new version of the film being
sent out to it just for audio issues but
now I just saw the movie again a few
days ago and noticed a few big
differences and the film's associate
editor Andy Leviton confirmed that there
are actually at least two different
versions of Spider-Man across the
spider-verse with different jokes
different dialogues and people are just
seeing different versions of it in the
theaters right now I suppose it's a kind
of A and B testing of jokes like when
the movie clue released in 1985 with one
of three different alternate endings
which is a marketing gimmick that failed
so on the home release and the TV
airings they merged all three together
into three back to back to back
alternate endings these across the
spider-verse alternate Cuts don't appear
to be any kind of marketing gimmick but
rather either updates that the animators
made in the days after the film's
initial release or just an inside joke
among the film's production so I am
going to break down all the changes
between these two different versions of
Spider-Man across the spider-verse and
please subscribe to all three channels
in the new rockstars Network this
channel for Easter egg breakdowns the
break room for our instant reactions and
after shows and the Deep dive for
special film analyzes from me and please
support us with a Miles Morales
Multiverse dive shirt which you can get
at nerd riot.shop okay the first
difference early in the movie when
Miguel is fighting the vulture his AI
assistant Lila pops up asking if he
wants her to call for backup he resists
at first but then he caves and then she
says she already did in version a Lila
says but I enjoyed that and she extends
a fist bump but in version B Lila says
but I enjoyed that and she takes a
selfie with Miguel with a bunny rabbit
filter over his face maybe they changed
it because for Lila to be able to take a
selfie with Miguel logically she'd have
to have some kind of camera function in
her floating AI projection to record his
face or really maybe they just didn't
want to make too much of a mockery of
the movie's villain in this opening
scene next difference also comes up in
the scene and version a there's a big
lead up to Miguel retracting his mask
showing his vampire fangs those fangs
reflecting in vulture's eyes vultures
screaming in fear and then the
helicopter Miguel so he holds back on
biting but version B we don't see any of
that build up just Miguel about to bite
the vulture and then the helicopter
shows up maybe the change was made
because his film doesn't really explore
Miguel's animalistic side and in the
re-edit they didn't want to set it up as
much but Gwen and Miles do call him a
vampire later when swinging around the
city okay next when Jeff Morales chases
after his son miles fighting the spot in
the street Jeff gets pulled into the
portal as well in version a Jeff reacts
and closer for just a few frames but in
version B there's a slightly longer beat
where Jeff groans and he kind of looks
around so this version Keeps Us in
Jeff's point of view a bit longer to set
up the great beat when Jeff needs to
make a leap of faith into the portal and
he just chickens out it runs down the
stairs just like his son did in the 2018
film later when Gwen goes to Jonathan's
apartment to digitally reconstruct the
moment he built a mini collider to
produce Dark Matter before sticking his
finger in the dark matter the spot says
it should work or vaporize being
everybody in this building and version a
he ends up by saying eh what the heck
but in version B he ends up by saying
which would not be good I think this is
a significant change because in one
version this spot is completely Carefree
about who he hurts in his Pursuit but in
the other he recognizes the recklessness
of his behavior and he expresses at
least a small amount of concern that he
might hurt other people I think the spot
is going to be revealed as a more
sympathetic Redemptive figure in the
next film and I think that's why they
made this change okay next when miles
meets pravicher prabhakar and Earth
50101 who improved her correct smiles
over chai tea in version a for Beecher
says would I ask you for a coffee coffee
with room for cream cream and Miles
responds I'm sorry I'm so sorry and he
drops his head in shame but in version B
Miles responds I'm sorry sorry man a bit
more defensively it's a subtle
distinction but I think it shows how
miles would as a teenager accustomed to
correcting people over things like ATM
machine would push back just a bit
against someone who's been a Spider-Man
not as long as he has your enjoyment of
Marvel's secret Invasion will not be
complete if you don't watch inside
Marvel on new Rockstar's new channel the
break room we are going to be answering
all the burning questions after each
episode and stop at nothing to
Scrolls in the MCU the break room is our
brand new Channel with breaking news
reactions after shows and some really
fun content that you've never seen from
us before on the break room you'll see
all the new Rockstar's faces you've come
to love as well as friends of the
channel new and old and celebrity guests
will be legally obligated to make
appearances there are some up there
already for real go look for yourself
join us for every episode of secret
Invasion as we pour over all the
evidence to figure out who it who isn't
a scroll in your hottest burning
questions coming out of every episode if
you don't want to miss a single clue
subscribe over at youtube.com breakroom
in R okay next when Hobie crashes miles
move at the moment in Malcolm X in
version a miles pops his head out from
behind the computer terminal asking
Hobie and there's no text over his head
or anything but at version B they do add
a little Hobie above miles head now
before maybe they felt Hobie Brown
smashing text in his intro was enough of
an introduction but some common feedback
is that many folks outside the UK could
not understand what the hell Hobie was
saying or even really what his name was
because the letters flash on screen
popping off it with cut out newspaper
text so maybe now for all of us babies
out there they proceed it with a
clarification little baby miles Hobie
okay next asthma baton crisis comes to
an end and miles is swooped into save
inspector Singh and that little kid on
the bridge all of them get caught under
Rubble but in version a Gwen rushes over
frantically grasping miles miles no no
no no no no no no please no come on and
then thankfully she finds him with the
kids still alive but in version B they
for whatever reason removed all of
hailee steinfeld's lines here she just
kind of stays silent as she lifts the
rubble now I'm not sure why they changed
this one version makes Gwen more likable
worried she's about to lose another
friend like she lost her Earth 65 Peter
but after the change you could say it
does set up miles later feeling betrayed
that Gwen wasn't really trying to save
him she was just trying to prevent a
cannon event from being disrupted next
they head to the spider society and when
Malala Windsor asks anybody spot the
spot and Jessica Drew responds ah very
funny anybody else got jokes in version
a every nearby spider person comes in
with a yellow text box with a pun but in
version B the text boxes are colored
blue why well yellow has always been the
text box color for miles in her
monologue in this movie and in the 2018
movie coloring these blue make Smiles
feel like more of an alienated Outsider
like he's not in on the joke with all of
them it's not what's inside his head
it's what all of them are saying okay
there's another change with Ben Reilly
when they're all chasing miles outside
the spider Society building and version
a Ben says this is called a sleeper hold
I'm using my bicep to constrictor and
then miles zaps everyone often but in
version B Ben says I've got you trapped
in my well-defined musculature so don't
even and then he gets cut off there the
new line draws even greater attention to
the insane vein that pops out of Ben's
bicep and the way that 90s Marvel Comics
were often drawn also considering how
mean everyone is two miles in this movie
maybe we also just don't need Ben Reilly
cutting up oxygen to his brain now some
say they might have cut Miles saying
sorry man I'm going home as he zaps
Miguel on the train but I confirmed he
does actually say that line in both
versions but I want to know from you do
you think these changes were necessary
did the animators just do this to
Mandela affect us in a Multiverse
support us with a Miles Morales
Multiverse dive shirt at nerd riot.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you